yo
bootleghead podcast uh we are here with
a legend right now man
mca what's cracking kev i'm chilling bro
i gotta tell you when i was a
a kid i had a big cousin who had all you
know the cd books used to be as [ __ ]
right right get all your [ __ ] compton's
most wanted [ __ ]
and uh i kind of got introduced i want
to say
as a child you and quick's beef was my
first introduction to like
rap beef right i was probably like i
don't know like 10 or 11
and uh you know you guys had a legendary
back and forth but um man it's it's so
dope to talk to you i've obviously i've
been in la for like three or four years
the first time you met man yes indeed
yes indeed uh you got your new album
that um how long have you been working
on this new album lessons
i've been working on it for about a year
and a half
um you know just trying to get the right
music together
you know uh try to get a couple of
features whatever
you know i don't really be big on
features i just try to do what i do you
know when i start recording a project
i usually just go into the studio
i get about three four producers and i
just have them just send me
beat after beat after beat after beat so
i might record up to 60 songs
right and then from there i just you
know
being in the game a while and having
relationships with certain cats
it enables me to pick up the phone and
be like hey
you know i need a verse i need a beat so
always primo always new york cats
you know you know i i kind of you know
extend their hand
as far as as far as my
my my my my uh
i want to say my contribution to hip hop
right it's been so long
so dude so just you know semi versus
send me beat so i've been recording this
record for about a year and a half
and i try to do a lot of songs and then
i'll
out of the 60 songs i might pick 30 and
then i'll send them to primo
and then premo i'll be like yeah no yeah
no
yeah no and then from there i just
basically just try to put whatever it
don't even matter on the amount of songs
i record
if it's 20 songs we put 20 songs out if
it's 15 we do 15 if it's 12 if it's 27
i mean i just try to do a gang of songs
so at least it'll go around the board
and have everybody or some a little
flavor for everybody
you and uh primo give me the roots of
your guys's relationship because
obviously you being from la primo's
you know originally from texas but we
associated with new york
um talk about y'all's relationship and
and and you know where it started um
i started rapping man back in the day
days you know
uh p rock seal smooth emzy
uh ice cube tone log school e d
so i i've been around for a while so
back in my days
record companies was big on promotional
tours yeah i had to go out you had to go
do in-store
sign autographs so around the time i
first got started
um primo and them had first got started
with gangstar
came in rest in peace guru rest in peace
i used to see him a lot on the road
promo tours and
one of my first major concerts was with
gangstar
at the celebrity theater in anaheim oh
no there's a celebrity theater in
phoenix too
yeah it was a celebrity theater in
anaheim and my first major show was
low profile wow
above the law okay cmw
and gangstar so so re
that's like such a gangster ass west
coast lineup and then gangstar
and then gangstar so you know they was
hot with the manifest record yep yeah
so i used to bump into them and a lot of
my early gigs
you know when i started touring was with
gangstar whether it was texas or
chicago cleveland always used to bump
into primo on them so
we got cool like that and then
me being signed to sony you know a lot
of my
deals in construction i had to go to new
york and deal with the
suit heads so yep i just called primo up
every time
you know primo coming into town he
picked me up from the airport
we go to his crew just hang out like
homies and we've
kept that relationship over the years
you know he used to remix my uh records
when i was over at uh sony
over at epic um so we just kept a
connection
you know primo used to take me around
all the shows the gigs
you know i got introduced to nas early
and busta rhymes and treach and a lot of
them cats man we used to just chill
so um we've built that rapport
over the years as to i can hit primo up
man
any time of day anytime a day night
whatever and
it's it's always a given you know primo
i need a beat or sometimes i just want
him to listen to [ __ ]
to make sure i'm on the right track
because as a producer
trust his ear god damn right he got that
hearing being a and you know producing
for everybody from me
to jill scott jay-z jay-z christina and
biggie you know so
he's had that he's had that track record
where he has that good ear
so me and primo's been knowing each
other for a long time and i respect that
that friendship relationship
outside of just the music you know
somebody you would cross paths with
at a concert or a show or whatever it's
the best and yeah
i i had one conversation with primo and
it was it was the best it was like
when you meet your idols yeah and it
like they don't
they don't [ __ ] up which you know
because sometimes you'll meet somebody
who you grow up
loving and and then you you meet them
and or you interview yourself
[ __ ] just like damn you're
disappointed but with primo we just
talked hip-hop and porn stars and all
kinds of whites
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's pretty well
that's primo right yeah primo can talk
you around everything every subject
every anything you know and like i said
that's from being as being a diverse
human being that primo has been and a
good [ __ ] he's always been there for
sure
let's go back to kind of how you got
started man like
obviously being from compton being
involved in the gang [ __ ] at what point
in time
did you decide to take hip hop serious
and realize that it might be like a way
out of the other [ __ ] that was going on
well you know like i said i started in
the height of you know
not to saying that you know gangbang
still exists and it's still out there or
whatever but
i started in the height of the area
around
ice tea with colors and nwa and easy
with boys in the hood and straight out
of compton and then
ice tea was six in the morning king tea
you know
shout out to the liquid crew man ice tea
are two guys who don't get enough
praise for what they did definitely my
dude tila
tila was man i mean every
every record that came out from tila in
that time
was just you know pay back some mother
and you better bring a gun
and all that [ __ ] man he was the
forefront of
what everybody could say was what
started compton hip-hop no disrespect
to my [ __ ] toddy t and mixed master
spade but as far as records could
went tila was that dude so
i was just a young cat you know trying
to bang in the neighborhood
whatever and todd was from my
neighborhood toddy t
shout out toddy t todd came out with a
song called the battle ram
you know battle ram was a neighborhood
jam
you know the derral gates police drug
sales whatever
so that kind of peaked my interest
of getting into the rap game and then
i took a summer vacation you know to
mississippi
and my cousin being in mississippi was
more
east coast than klein so that's when i
started hearing
rap music right you get me eric b and
rakim and
[ __ ] utfo and roxanne chante
treacherous three grand master flash so
i'm like oh [ __ ]
like so it peaked my interest is to want
to take it to a different level
as to just going home and rapping about
the block
because that's what i did i wanted to be
a toddy t
or spade i want to rap about shrag new i
want to talk about the
the the police harassment and who we had
beef with and whatever whatever but then
when i got introduced to like i said
rock him and eric be his president
when you hear [ __ ] like that or epmd you
gots to chill
right you start going wow like it's
something else to this [ __ ] than just
speaking on
what you see exactly so from that
i just took the skills and what i've
learned from the east coast rappers of
learning how to
put together verses in a perfect song
and to
rap about [ __ ] outside of compton
you know so that's what sparked my real
interest and want to turn from just a
little mixtape or tdk selling
talking about we this and we that and we
bang or this is our hood
and they wanted me to take it further
the songs like growing up in the hood or
drive by miss daisy or to get more you
know
personal with the rap so it started
around when i i started listening to
east coast rap i mean i mean east coast
rock was big for me man
real talk yeah i mean i think that that
was always kind of prevalent in your
[ __ ] like
that because i you know i mean even if
we we could fast forward to now you know
your first singles got conway exactly by
primo
definitely but i do think that um
if you think back to that era of like
west coast hip-hop like how
even even ice cube you know with
america's most wanted which i think is
his best
body of work um was heavily influenced
by
by the by of new york and tapped in with
the bomb squad definitely
and chuck d and all that um
at what age did you initially get
involved in
gang banging because i i do feel like
we like you said it's is still around
but in
when you were growing up it was kind of
it was it was
it was it was the it was saying it was
new to the world
exactly right exactly like the crips and
blood [ __ ] was something that
was starting to become like a mainstream
thing but
but now we all know what crips and
bloods are right i mean as a young kid
i was naive to it i mean i lived in the
center of it and didn't know [ __ ] about
it
as a as a [ __ ] five six seven year
old kid right
all i knew was saturday morning cartoons
riding my bike up and down the street
and
not knowing that the dudes right down
the block was claiming [ __ ]
and selling drugs and i was naive to it
but as you grow and you start seeing
and you start adapting to your
environment and you seeing the dudes
hanging on the corners and
dudes your age riding around in fancy
cars and
and whatever so my introduction to that
was around you know 12
13 years old what year was this [ __ ]
this had to be like 85 86
you know it was treacherous round you
know i was
go i would go to the bus stop getting
ready to go to school and then i started
getting introduced to
[ __ ] sweating you and [ __ ] i didn't
know what the [ __ ] that was about
i'm sitting at the bus stop getting
ready to go to school and it's like
[ __ ] where the [ __ ] you from
and what you doing over here and why you
got that on and what you wearing that
hat for and why you got there and then
i'm looking like
god damn this and that was the reality
of it so the
and as at that age it's funny because
before that
i dealt with none of that but then once
when you start to look like you might
need things
once you hit that age next it's just
like a common thing
you either getting sweated or you
sweating the [ __ ] or y'all
jumping out on [ __ ] and
that's like i said it was the product of
my environment this is what i
adapted to when i was able to understand
and know what gang banging was about and
trying to grow up in a section and
trying to protect your section and
represent and it's about you and the
homies and whatever
so it was a transition i think growing
up on the west
and being in that environment because if
i probably grew up somewhere else it had
probably been a different thing
do you think that you having to deal
with that [ __ ] where people would bang
on you or
or sweat you like you said like did that
kind of force you to like
figure out like i need to i need to have
something to say
well yeah i mean you either gonna get
down or lay down at that aspect
so it's either you gonna belong you're
gonna belong to something and represent
something or you're gonna be
a [ __ ] out there who's probably
gonna end up
at the like belly of the beast because
there was no saving i don't give a [ __ ]
you could say you wasn't from nowhere
and then the [ __ ] sweats you
harder
so it's best to be long
then to not and get caught up in a world
of [ __ ] that you can't handle so
that was my thing about you know the
gang banging [ __ ] and
claiming the hood or or getting courted
in or whatever
it was the sense of feeling like i
belonged and represented
you know what i'm saying and i had 15 20
30 other [ __ ]
who was representing and we are for the
protection of whatever and if nuggets
didn't like it then we handled that
accordingly to why we did it but like i
said i think
it's it's not a choice it's being in a
situation in an environment
that we grew up in is like that's what
you did
yeah it's funny because i just had this
conversation with somebody
i had a cousin who did like 15 years in
prison right
right uh i have two cousins one of them
is half mexican half white
he's in the mexican mafia my other
cousin
who who actually passed away in prison
recently um
not a racist guy big hip-hop head but
literally was in for 20 years
and how did he join the aryan nation
it's a survival thing it's like
definitely it's like you know i remember
he got out for a couple of years and i
took him to a bust of rhymes concert
and it was like the best night of his
life but this [ __ ] i
like you gotta wear long sleeve shirts
bruh yeah but like you said it's like yo
it's what you're it's like you got to
adapt
you have to wait down and lay down i
mean you have to adapt to certain
situations that were put in especially
if you one of those
young young men who grow
who grew up or got tossed in a situation
to where it's either gone
you either a part of this and gonna be
long or are you gonna represent
and you gonna up you're gonna uphold
this [ __ ] to the best of your ability or
you're gonna be like i said you're going
to be a sheep to the lions
what are your thoughts on on now because
i do feel like
it's just interesting that like there's
people who move to la
like artists will move to la and then
you know
all of a sudden they're affiliated with
certain sets and and and they got big
homies and
i i don't know how like you know there's
like r
b singers and [ __ ] that are like banging
like hard as [ __ ] and it's like wait a
minute like
you know like what are your thoughts on
kind of how how gangbanging has
evolved currently because i do feel like
there's a lot of um there's a lot like
like there's a lot of faces to certain
you know sets that are like they you
that aren't from here personally
you know what i'm saying well i'll take
it i look at that as
a lot of people get into situations to
where they feel
like it's just like if a dude
joined the cub scouts or went out and
joined the football
team or whatever the aspect of that is
to toughen up or make you
uh seem like you know you're protected
or being something that you ain't
some dudes have to adapt to that
situation some dudes have to feel like
you know that's my
that's my foundation of what i've seen
or what i've wanted to become
uh if for for dudes like me who grew up
here
and firsthand witnessed gang banging
and grew up in it there was a certain
way and code that you belonged or you
got
put on the neighborhood you know the
the new days quote of gang banging
is to each his own to is what i say it's
what is accepted and what ain't accepted
from
whatever gang feels like this is what
they do
i mean i don't know sometimes it might
be a popularity contest or it might be
hey i've always wanted to be a part so
is it a backwards step to me i think it
is but like i said
some dudes is to each his own and they
feel like that they have to have
that that background to make them
official
you feel me so i don't really speak on
it because then we don't want to get
entangled in the situation of
telling people that they not original or
whatever because if you feel that's you
that's you
myself i know the certain codes
coming from compton at 12 13 years old
knowing what it took or what it what had
to be done
to be initiated into a gang as to
nowadays it's just like hey you're down
you down show us later bring the homies
around the city and it's all good so
it's different codes like i said
different times i mean gangbanging is
commercialized now
back in my days when we didn't glorify
it
i mean people knew where we were from
what we represented but there was no way
in [ __ ]
once the 90s hit yeah it became like
i remember when there was the crips
versus or the crips and bloods album
banging on wax
right and i was like wait what yeah it
started to become
commercialized because record labels
looked at it as as a promotional tool to
sell records
i mean honestly we couldn't do that [ __ ]
back in my days when i got signed to
sony and i was on epic records
the home of michael jackson and chardee
no way in [ __ ] you finna put bandanas on
the video
and you finna be on the record talking
about you a [ __ ] from so and so
the way we did it is we did it with our
color symbolizations or
[ __ ] will wear blue and they videos
the bloods will wear red in a videos
and we left it at that now that
record labels see that it's influenced
by our [ __ ]
so he's saying he this now you got a
million
fans who buying this product because he
representing what we're not gonna stop
that
and claim whatever you want to you want
more blue bandanas you want more red
bandanas
get them the more the merrier because
it's now commercialized
and people ain't scared of the situation
no more not to say gang banging ain't
official but like i said back in our
days
[ __ ] had security in the
lobbies of record labels because they
were scared of [ __ ] walking in them
now you like bring all your crew in
[ __ ] you get so it's just the way that
[ __ ] have monetized it
and made it to where we can put it on
film
you can claim it and then there it is
[ __ ] it long as we making a dollar off
of it we don't really we're not
intimidated
if somebody in your entrepreneur will
turn the other cheek we'll turn the
other cheek
yes um i wanted to ask you about
something specific that i just wanted to
get your take on
and that's the six nine situation he
just was out in l.a
yeah for like three or four days
obviously
just out here being very disrespectful
um trolling the [ __ ] out of everybody uh
um he pulled up to nipsey's uh
memorial you know next to nipsey store
um i had heard well first of all
you know what are your what is your take
on like on that specific
like like him coming out to l.a and kind
of just showing out i know he's got
and then i wanted to ask you a follow-up
dude i just wanted to get your initial
kind of perception
it's expected for
dudes who are looking for
the limelight
promotional tactic and stunts are
heavy
real [ __ ] don't move like [ __ ]
real [ __ ] move like real [ __ ] move
so
that situation to me is all about
numbers it's all about promotion
it's all about controversy and when you
got them three things
you'll stay in the motherfucker's mouth
all day
exactly whether it's good or bad they
don't give a [ __ ]
i've always been told promotion is
promotion
whether it's good or bad [ __ ]
is talking about you yeah there's that
cliche
oh there's no such thing as bad press
none none
so unless you're tory lanez anyway
continue so look
he comes out and he's the talk of the
town
now nobody's really real [ __ ]
i'm not worried about that situation you
got a lot of [ __ ] people
who feel that it's disrespectful
whatever whatever
but on a real day he's not gonna do that
type of [ __ ]
knowing that his real [ __ ] standing
ground i heard he did that at like seven
in the morning
of course you do it like i said it's all
publicity
and i like i said i don't have nothing
to say about dude
dude do what he do he trying to make his
money that's his thing
it's all about the money let's let's
face it it's all about the money with
certain cats
it's not about being you know loyal or
true
or whatever so i don't understand why a
lot of [ __ ] are
tripping off of the cat because
it's all been that gimmicky situation
from the game
that's what he does from the gate so
don't be shocked by the antics
you give me just like a [ __ ] who
want to promote a movie and go downtown
and skydive off of the tallest building
or
tight rope across or anything for
promotion
is to keep a motherfucker's name in in
people's mouths
because the quieted you are and you
don't
talk about it [ __ ] don't die
away in the wind
so i have to keep my name in the public
so you do certain [ __ ] you do dumb [ __ ]
yeah i was gonna say because with with
someone like him coming to la obviously
he's got a lot of security of course um
i'm not sure if he had like had to pay
for any protection out here or not
um but do you think that like
i a lot of people i know i've spoken
with a lot of a lot of
uh homies that are are from out here who
are you know some g's that like like six
nine kind of like
do you think he kind of cracked the
street code or maybe just
i think he's the first person to like do
what he's doing
openly there's been other snitches that
are of course of course
people but like for him to be so outward
with it do you think he kind of
cracked the the street code and and do
you think
that like there's a way to move forward
where
because the snitch thing has always been
that one code that
is the unbreakable thing right right
still successful he's calling people out
like i mean it's
it's it's it's kind of crazy but y'all
but you have to understand
the snitch code the the snitch code
stands for real [ __ ]
right it only stands for real [ __ ] me
and glasses alone talked about that like
if you're like a civilian if you're
if you're not mixed up in [ __ ] you you
should snitch
and then like if something happens to
you right you're a normal person right
or the police
but if you're you know g malone
like nah i'm not calling the police i'm
gonna handle my [ __ ] the way i handle my
[ __ ] cause that because because i
this is my life exactly your reputation
is your life
at stake and your word is at stake but
why are people so
like adamant to put the snitch jacket
on [ __ ] who never was
real from the first place that's where
you getting [ __ ] confused
don't give a [ __ ] stop looking at the
money
the chains the [ __ ] streams
and all that stop looking at that [ __ ] a
[ __ ] was never
real from negate so how can you put the
code of you should follow it why because
a [ __ ] was hanging with
street [ __ ] and because a [ __ ]
was rapping
what and they allowed that guy to be
around him now i mean
if you're gonna pay a [ __ ] then
fine if they gonna you know
i and this is coming from the [ __ ]
hell yeah we gonna let that [ __ ] hang
around us if he kicking up 150
200 grand we you think we not
[ __ ] come hang
right we benefiting from that right
everyone's getting paid
okay but you gotta understand
when you put a [ __ ] situation
and he's not
real from the gate it's gonna backfire
he's gonna tell on you i mean are you
surprised
you shouldn't be you get me
just like with with with my man george
floyd
and the police brutality motherfucker's
been doing that [ __ ] forever
it's on video now okay and i get it and
it's [ __ ] up that
my boy had to lose his life in that
situation
but you shouldn't be surprised
and that's what gets me sometimes is
when [ __ ] go
oh no i can't believe it how you how you
can't
this [ __ ] just happened last week around
the corner but it wasn't on film
[ __ ] never been real never
let me tell you something and this has
been going on since
hip-hop and money has been around the
more money you got
the more [ __ ] courageous you feel and
that go with every [ __ ] rapper
i don't give a [ __ ] if you're a street
rapper
and whether you a real [ __ ] or
you was the poindexter [ __ ]
in the crew the minute you get bread in
your pocket and chains
and whatever and you [ __ ] a couple of
[ __ ] you're gonna start feeling like
mighty man
i'm untouchable i'm the hardest [ __ ] on
the block i'm the hardest [ __ ] but the
first time a [ __ ] tests your hardness
you fold and you're gonna tell so
we shouldn't be confused by the fact of
what that situation is you shouldn't
he's not he's not a a nigga's rapper
he's not
my rapper he's not you're a rapper he's
not whatever no he's like 13 year old
kids who like tic toc
thank you yeah okay don't get it
confused because a lot of [ __ ]
are going so what he told
so what that's your kid in there
vouching for him
because let me tell you if you're a
grown ass [ __ ] and you
banging that [ __ ] something is
physically wrong
yeah something is physically wrong now i
get it
the little the little girls the little
the strip club girls who dance into his
music
and the little kids who like the
colorful and the hair and
i get it i get it but
let's not be confused for a dude like me
or a nip or you or whoever
it's not my music hell no so
let's not get confused about
who vouchers for my man you gave me
a lot of youth a lot of a lot of kids
bump
that and that's where you know because
you pick up your phone as a 15 year old
kid
and go bingo
because me as a grown ass man i'm not
picking up my phone going i'm finna
download this [ __ ] and bump it in my car
right it's for the so you you have to
you you have to understand what the
situation is and that's what i say about
that
disrespectful yeah
but you probably should expect that from
those type of [ __ ] you brought
up the george floyd thing
you came up in la probably at the peak
of like the lapd being
just the worst right obviously um
without what happened with ronnie king
kind of highlighted that on a bigger
scale but there was you know like you
said this that happened so much
that people just didn't see what what
are some of your experiences growing up
in compton
with the police because i just remember
watching uh
was it was it uh boys in the hood or was
it uh
menace it was menace where the cops were
just pieces of [ __ ] in there and i was
oh definitely
i mean but ever since the days i could
remember
being a young cat growing up in compton
um
it was normal it was normal to the fact
that
you sort of expected it right whenever
you saw the police hit your corner like
you knew if we were
if we were hanging out in the
neighborhood at the hood house and
chilling
and the police hit the block
nine times out of tna for the stop you
finna be sitting on the curve
and two or three of you is going to be
going to jail for
who knows what right and then you might
get punched up you might get kicked up
you might won't he won't you get thrown
in the car you go down to the holding
tank
they hold you to two three o'clock in
the morning and they let you go
it's been going on ever since
you you riding down compton boulevard
and you pass them and they coming out of
parking lot
off another street as soon as you make
that eye contact
they finna pull you over don't know [ __ ]
ain't ran a plate don't know if you
coming from work or school or whatever
no matter if you fit the profile of
[ __ ]
in compton who gang bang from these
neighborhoods
we're gonna pull you over we're gonna
harass
jack [ __ ] you up do whatever and it's a
daily routine
so we might you might have had a billion
complaints
but who gave a [ __ ] you get me who gave
a [ __ ]
because we were just young [ __ ] in
compton and we were in our own world
and nobody gave a [ __ ] outside of
compton
what compton did or whatever it's
something that we lived with and we
dealt with was it wrong was it [ __ ] up
of course you just accepted it as the
normal
it's normal right it's just as normal as
a [ __ ] standing outside on his
porch and a [ __ ] hitting the block to
do a drive-by
it happens look what we had
it happens which we got we in compton in
a small little section and got about 30
different [ __ ] gangs
[ __ ] banging on every different street
block park
avenue corner on top of that selling
drugs
yeah so police dealt with
us how they dealt with us these
everybody
banging everybody's selling drugs so we
gonna go from neighborhood to
neighborhood
and we just [ __ ] with [ __ ] that's
what it took
yo look man quick break from the podcast
and tell you about odd socks
all right they're our official sponsor
they support what we do here at the
bootleg kit podcast
all right they got the nickelodeon
joints they got these uh
yo shout out to ghostbusters i might
keep those um anyway
what you gotta do is hit that
oddsoxofficial.com
if you want to support what i do the
bootleghead podcast then support our
partners odd socks go buy some socks man
holidays are coming up
oddssocksofficial.com
keyword bootleg kev you're getting 20
off of the most comfortable socks in the
world
shout out to odd socks talk about how
did you
end up becoming involved with menace to
society
um one of the best you know just one of
one of my favorite movies ever but
obviously one of the
the best you know movies that kind of
depicted
the 90s exactly um
we had just came off of colors you know
iced tea
colors and whatever and then cube did uh
boys
then they had south central with glenn
plummer and then um
tupac had went over and did [ __ ] uh
juice
right so those movies were going around
so you had two young cats out of la the
hughes brothers
who wrote this movie you know they went
to film school
all that they had did a lot of tupac's
videos
brenda had a baby holler if you hear me
a lot of his first videos the hughes
brothers did
so they got this script they took it the
new line
new line liked it knew when they had a
relationship with with pock you know
they felt like okay
y'all pop bingo there's minister society
and uh you know [ __ ] happened with poc
whatever he didn't make the film
but it was still a good film uh they
called me up
like hey we was looking for a character
i think they was trying to get rin to do
it too
so um ren had read i read for it
uh i guess they liked it you know my
reading
they called me back i didn't really
think of it like i said i'm still a
[ __ ]
in the neighborhood um i think i just
dropped music to drive by
so i was still on my banging [ __ ] with
the music and the records and whatever
so i really didn't think nothing about
it and then movies i'm like that's cube
and
tupac [ __ ] dang and then ren was nwa
i'm just mca from kante's most wanted
i've i'm here
you know so i'm like [ __ ] ain't gonna
give me no part and then my
[ __ ] manager called me one day
and say because i was on tour
and he called me and said you gotta come
back to la cause they gave you the part
and then
that's when i met jada and tyron and
lorenz and
like i said poc was there in the first
couple of readings cause he was still in
the movie so
it was a it was a good career lifter for
me
and for the fact that it dealt with
actual [ __ ] that was going on in in la
compton so i think that movie kind of
generated a
a following to where it was a good cult
classic because it really showed what
was going on [ __ ] in the projects or
whatever
and then for me who had been in
similar situations it just kind of it
just kind of
kind of meshed you know what i'm saying
yeah it's crazy too because
obviously your role in that movie was
kind of like the
the the the down ass big homie yeah the
[ __ ] who done been there right
unseen it i haven't been in and out of
jail i didn't grew up in the
neighborhood
so i know the [ __ ] to get in and not
into
and it's just like any any [ __ ]
neighborhood
who grow up and who's claiming the
neighborhood you always got that one
[ __ ] that's been through a lot
of [ __ ]
and who could tell you a lot of [ __ ]
about being from the neighborhood and
representing and whatnot
and the pitfalls of it so a lot of
people don't know tupac's original like
like you know suppose supposed to be
involvement in that movie what was like
he was supposed to be in the movie
originally tupac was supposed to play
um uh sharif okay
so my boy vontae sweet uh ended up
playing him but
that's the role that they wanted him to
play and
he didn't you know pop coming off a
juice
and poetic justice and then you know his
records or whatever
he was a very vocal you know upfront
[ __ ]
pock was that wasn't the type of [ __ ]
to play the back roll
or to play to just innocent bystander or
the conservative [ __ ]
he was the forefront and he wanted to
express
that so he wanted to kind of express
why he was being the muslim kid
or the one the voice of reason he wanted
to depict that and show
why and i don't think they wanted to
show that
and that's what made the movie for his
situation kind of fall apart because you
know
park's very adamant i don't give a [ __ ]
i need [ __ ] to know
why i turned into the why why i am the
way i am and
well i do kill a bunch of [ __ ] or what
somebody killed my mama and i wouldn't
chop their head off or some [ __ ]
show why i'm this person now and they
didn't want to do it so
it kind of went to a bump in head
situation
to where you know everybody know what
happened with him and the hughes
brothers and that was the result
of the bumping heads at the [ __ ]
table
did you and poc have a solid
relationship i was cool with poc
we did a couple of shows together um you
know he used to bang my records when he
was
you know locked up so we had a
relationship to where when we saw each
other it was mutual respect you feel me
yo you you know with compton's most
wanted music to drive by obviously a
west coast classic
talk about like i feel like there was
the culture of the drive-by shooting
right back then
right i feel like that's something that
really became prevalent in l.a and
definitely was related to directly
related to the gang [ __ ] that was going
on during that time
um do you remember like when that
started to become something to really
worry about
because i'm assuming it it it became
like it seemed like at a certain point
in time it was just kind of the normal
right like yeah
like you you said earlier it was kind of
normal between like
for me i i just know that
in between a period of like 89
in like 93
[ __ ] was gang banging hard like like
hard
hard like even before then if you want
to say like
87 86 everybody was gang
and it was rough gang banging like it
wasn't like
oh okay now you'll see crips and bloods
in the same place
shaking hands getting money together and
not that [ __ ] wasn't doing it back
then
you had certain [ __ ] who could do that
you had certain oh geez
who could maybe pull up in a blood
neighborhood and get out and
and talk to [ __ ] like but for me
[ __ ] was on the kill war path back
then
so drive-bys was real heavy
around that time like [ __ ] maybe every
other day
[ __ ] was getting smoked and then
everybody had pistols back in
[ __ ] is breaking into gun shops and in
surpluses and and still
especially when the raid happened [ __ ]
is breaking into surplus stores and
stealing guns so now
everybody you know got weapons
and when everybody got guns i'm talking
about they don't even need to my
[ __ ] go do a drive-by by itself
and i've known a lot of [ __ ] who do it
[ __ ] it i think i'm getting in my car
tonight and going to hit them [ __ ]
like it was it was just not to say it
was the thing
but it was happening to where mamas was
sleeping on the floors and putting their
kids on the floors at night because
guaranteed somebody's getting drunk
somebody coming through tonight
definitely and it was a co
you know [ __ ] just shoot up innocently
but like i said
drive-bys was very heavy around that
time
i think two something from the outside
looking in if someone's watching this
that isn't from la and doesn't
understand the way that l.a politics
work
a lot of people just always associate
crips and bloods as beefing right
right but but it's more of a
neighborhood thing yeah
i mean because there's there's [ __ ] sets
that beat with each other yeah you got
crips and then especially if you have
large sets you know you especially if
you have large [ __ ] sets who have
multiple streets and multiple blocks
so you know you got crips from this
block who might not get along with the
crips
ten blocks down even though they're all
from the same neighborhood
i mean even even where i represented
from
there were different streets you had
this you had
coradon you had 153rd you had bar clay
you had
taper all these streets are in one
neighborhood
but every different crews hang on these
different streets
so you could have beef with a [ __ ] from
across the street
who's from your next same neighborhood a
lot of that went on and you had crips
who beefed with crips
you know crypt sets who beef with other
[ __ ] sets
and so on so how big of a deal was it
because i know
you know when nipsey died it just it
really [ __ ] man it [ __ ] me up i'm no
nip for
since 09 and um you know but
when he passed away um big u had kind of
helped
put together that day of unification
where everybody
can't pulled up you know on on that
intersection and
and it was like it was it was i didn't
realize the uh
significance of how big of a deal it was
that a lot of those people were
in the same place in a peaceful manner
because a lot of a lot of neighborhoods
beef and have been beefing for
decades like and i i put it to the
[ __ ] analysis of the hatfields
and the mccoys
right you go you got [ __ ] who was
beefing before you was even born
so it's that tradition of beefing and
it's just like
damn yeah i was standing in the same
spot as them [ __ ]
y'all been killing them [ __ ] for
decades you get me
and vice versa so
that basically nip's passing sort of
represented
trying to unify
[ __ ] on the aspect of not just are you
from over here
i'm from over here [ __ ] you [ __ ] you you
know
it kind of it kind of led to the to the
place of trying to
show that [ __ ] don't have to
kill [ __ ] just over [ __ ] i get it
y'all represent there we represent here
but this was a dude who
basically tried to [ __ ] with everybody
whether it was [ __ ] whether it was blood
whether you was from the enemy
neighborhood from 15 years ago or
whether whatever
i tried to [ __ ] with everyone so that's
to me what that represent as far as big
you and nipping them and him passing
and everybody trying to show unification
together it was to show that
the outside world sees us just vicious
[ __ ] gang-banging ass vicious
drive-by killing [ __ ]
and it's bigger than that or it's what
is beyond that
so coming together shows people that
these [ __ ] that y'all look at
as these vicious [ __ ]
can can set aside their beasts from long
standing and
some [ __ ] might not even know why we
beef you get me
i just started gang banging and i know
we hate them [ __ ] over there right
right right i'm not old enough to know
what we believe
about but all i know is the minute i
start claiming over here we cross out
them [ __ ] and we say [ __ ] them
and the funny thing about it is six
years ago
i was in the same class as that
[ __ ] i think
we was playing kickball together outside
and whatever so
it it just showed that we can set aside
[ __ ]
for a mother for for my [ __ ] who
was already on that aspect like i got i
don't know where i'm from
but i got no problem with you my [ __ ]
if you ain't got no problem with me i
understand what happened back then
and i would never live that [ __ ] down
and i will always
know where i come from but [ __ ]
if you want to get me on the song
your blood hell yeah let's do it right
you want me
you want to beat from me or want me to
come to your video or we know how to get
money
or we can do this together man that's
going to be better for you and me in the
long run
you get me talk about um a lot of
newer rap fans might have just heard you
for the first time on goodkid mad city
right which is one of the greatest
hip-hop albums ever um
shout out to kendrick shout out to
kendrick shout out to kendrick shout out
to top dog dre
um just that that record is like
just the way it switches up and then you
come in it's like oh yeah that was that
mean that was probably one of the things
that was probably one of the best you
know uh guest appearances i've done or
working with kendrick
because my dude know
what he wanted he already he sees his
vision he sees his direction
and he came about at a different
approach than what we usually used to as
far as west coast artists
who come from that situation you know
poverty you know gang banging
we usually turn out the the cmws the
nwas the cubes the whatever
and he was able to
[Music]
take it to a different level almost like
from the perspective of the kid who
grows up in that
i grew up everybody banging around me
everybody's selling dope my brother my
uncle my
[ __ ] and i am the straightforward kid
but i'm still here so i get to witness
everything not that i'm a part of it
because even though
i don't have to say it they gonna
protect me or they gonna affiliate me
with over here or whatever
but i'm just a kid on the straight path
who see the pitfalls
and i'm trying to avoid that so as soon
as i hooked up with him he knew what he
wanted he knew where he wanted to go
how he wanted he was telling me [ __ ] i
want you to do this i want you to do
this i want you to do that
and you got to respect the [ __ ]
like that he didn't come into the game
playing with nothing i'm not going to
play around with this [ __ ]
were you like aware because obviously at
that point in time kendrick was
definitely buzzing
dread yeah section 80 already came out i
wasn't aware of kendrick at all
so you weren't aware of like the
magnitude of like yo this [ __ ]
i i uh started [ __ ] with kendrick
because my son's sister knew of him
and she called me and said they were
trying to get in contact with me
i didn't know anything about kendrick i
didn't know about section 80 none of
that [ __ ] no just like
i mean all right my son's sister called
me and said eight
uh this guy named kendrick he's messing
with dre
blah blah blah they want to get you on
the song and i was like yeah okay
what was it that did because you know
there's so many
iconic rappers from compton but i
thought it was so dope that he put you
on that record because it wasn't like
expected and it was very like i'm pretty
sure it wasn't expected from anyone
no i remember i saw that i was like oh
[ __ ] yeah this one got mc8
on the [ __ ] album about compton like
jesus christ
like i said i didn't even i didn't even
i put nothing to it when i came when i
showed up at the studio
i mean we recorded the song in carson
right at the spot
so i just looked at it is my nigga's one
of these up-and-coming rappers he got
skills
and blah blah and then i think the
minute after i recorded the song i went
home that night
and then everything was kendrick
kendrick kendrick
damn i'm like oh he signed the dre and
humpty woo
and then next day you know aftermath hit
me and
top dog and punch and [ __ ] was like
hey
and i was like they was like you know
you're the only [ __ ]
who got to be on the record you drake
and i think mary j yeah that was it
they didn't let anybody else on the
record so i was like whoa
okay so good look that's why it's a
good-looking drake
uh tde all that because he could have
chose anybody
yeah especially with dre behind him you
know dre would be like
i don't want that [ __ ] i want
that but when they said dre
said [ __ ] it cool i just looked at it as
they
they looked at it as i was a [ __ ]
coming from compton
who my whole career i was just one path
i didn't try to go here here come here
or here i just stuck to cmw
type of [ __ ] the neighborhood whatever
so that song was perfect
to try to throw me on i also feel like
it was a dope homage to your
career because you're somebody who
is very underappreciated in the grand
scheme of
when we discuss west coast hip hop
definitely you're very underrated
you're uh catalog is is you know
fire and i feel like that was a dope
like tip to what you've been
doing i i i took that from his point of
view as well
i looked at it as you know he
respected true west coast hip-hop
and coming from compton you know we got
dre
we got you know quick is there you know
so i'm like but i've always stuck to
that
you've always been i've always been
consistent with what i do
so coming from compton to pay i'm like
he's already [ __ ] with dre you know
what i'm saying so
i just looked at it like yeah let's get
somebody that we
feel has always represented the city of
compton
always been consistent and like you said
underrated and don't get that much shine
and pay a mod so
i didn't even i didn't even question
money or anything
that's fine when they hit me up i just
went to the studio i wasn't like oh well
he signed the dre how much y'all finna
pay me
i went to the studio dropped the verse
shook my [ __ ] hand
and we bounced and i think i heard from
them like three months later and they
was like dre
and aftermath and i was like whoa this
is gonna be some big [ __ ]
fire so shut up we're gonna do the very
first bathroom break in the bootleg head
podcast history cause i'm about to piss
on myself
i'm gonna hit this restaurant real quick
we back at it
yo shout out to you for not smoking
backwards like everybody else right oh
yeah man
backwards [ __ ] me up man i don't know
why [ __ ] got on the back woods that's
like the [ __ ]
yeah everybody's smoking backwoods i'm
like i can't do it man
i can't um you talked about uh
obviously dre being involved in goodkid
mad city dre being the
you know the consensus compton guy
across the country you know
when we think of compton like he's
probably the first rapper that the world
thinks of
did you and dre ever have any sort of
dialogue or like what was y'all's
dynamic coming up because obviously you
were a factor and he was
that guy dre was dre has always just
been a cool [ __ ] to me
i mean i've never you know had the
pleasure
outside of [ __ ] with kendrick of
[ __ ] with dre
big mad respect because you know he's
one of the he's the he's
the best [ __ ] as far as what he
do
you give me so anybody who would be
you know gifted with a dre
track or just a [ __ ] emphasis or just
that
the input of telling you which way to go
would be a [ __ ]
the greatest but uh we've always had
good uh rapport i mean
every time i would see him out in public
or go to parties or whatever whatever
we've always laughed and chuckled and
been cool
you know so you know primo [ __ ] with
him a lot you know so
he primo would go over and tell him you
know [ __ ] with eight and we working
so
always good [ __ ] always good [ __ ] talk
about so the new album
um is primo the executive producer
essentially
primo executive produced uh wreck we did
a record uh two years ago called which
way is west right
uh he executive produced he um
you know had a lot of input you know his
label
so on this record it was basically to
focus on me
trying to get you know ride the wave of
trying to
you know continue what i've been doing
for [ __ ] the last 20 years
so he's been a consultant on the record
you know like i said i sent him all the
beats i sent him all the tracks
he listens to him you know gives me
advice on what not to do
or maybe you need to do this or maybe do
this one on this song
he mixes the song so he he always has
an input when i put out records i try to
include him because like you said
he's one of the greatest producers he's
dealt with a lot of different diverse
artists
so he has a great ear so he's got yeah
one of the best deers ever um
and and it's it's crazy because working
with like
i feel like griselda and what conway and
westside gunn and benny are doing right
now is like
some of my favorite [ __ ] going on in hip
hop like they're doing that traditional
[ __ ] yeah
you think a traditional greedy rap
and [ __ ] grimy [ __ ] yeah that's what you
hear when you hear them
yeah now i was gonna say like how how
tapped in are you with the new [ __ ]
that's happening because obviously
i listened to a lot like i said i got a
16 year old son right
shout out quran uh um plays football
quarterback uh he always he
now he'd be up on all y'all [ __ ] hey i
tell him
i'm going to bootleg cab oh my god i got
to go
take me so um he's a 16 year old kid so
he's up on all the new [ __ ] i mean what
nba young boy all that [ __ ] yeah little
dirk
right uh [ __ ] uh g herbal
right right right she he listens to it
all and he loves it
yo it's it's dope too because you
actually you dm me
yeah and not a lot of artists are are
like on top of their [ __ ] like i was
like oh [ __ ] of course like mca oh yeah
i'm gonna be i'm one [ __ ] who
and i know a lot of people don't do it
because they bought people on the side
and i even got people
you know sometimes you got to get people
on your team that can whatever but
i'm the type of [ __ ] that i hit
you up personally i don't
i don't play that at all you know it's
just somebody running your page or
right right right right i handle all my
[ __ ]
i answer all my fans i deal with you
know
that's how i stay working i mean i i do
a million verses
a week because i'm able to connect with
[ __ ]
i don't just be like oh i got my cousin
running my page and whatever
dude send me emails respond dude send me
dms
if it's business or even sometimes
[ __ ] just want to say hey
y'all get a lot of [ __ ] that
just be like man i just wanted to tell
you
you you the [ __ ] or i love your [ __ ] and
i respond right back
yeah or cool or good looking or whatever
and i ain't trying to hold a
conversation with you but
i have enough respect for fans to
at least give them that you know what
i'm saying a lot of dudes i get it
they don't want to deal with
[ __ ] you know i'm too big
i don't want to respond whatever what
but me i don't give [ __ ] how big you are
you gotta connect with the [ __ ]
they're spending their money
those are yeah that's that they're the
reason why you have a man come on man a
way to feed your family man you gotta
connect with the [ __ ] whether
and i get it some [ __ ] be
irritating too
definitely some [ __ ] be
irritating they ask the stupidest
questions
and just [ __ ] and you have to sit there
sometime and be like
huh but i still deal with it
it's it's the situation that i put
myself in so to speak
i i had to i had to give the right and
and whatever and make records and
whatever and with that you were you were
gained fans
let me ask you something you're you're
um beef with quick which i know you've
talked about
to the death right um anybody who wants
to kind of
dive into that there's plenty of content
out there of you talking about what
happened
um do you think that you
and and quick's beef resulted in
because every time some something like
that happens
people choose sides like do you think it
it it resulted in you losing any
opportunities or
like you losing out on anything because
people might have
like chosen up or perceived you a
certain way during that
during that period um i've never looked
at it like that because i've always
looked at myself as the underground kid
100 i've never looked at myself as the
kid
that the [ __ ] would want to
come to period
and i always accepted that in mind
erased it
i i never felt like oh [ __ ]
this [ __ ] getting this and i
ain't getting it i've never felt that
never because at the end of the day
i can make some money i love to write
and do hip-hop my bills is paid
boom my kids ain't starving
and ain't struggling and don't have
[ __ ]
holy shoes and looking for a handout
i'm fine i've had opportunities right
that came along that fit me i mean i had
the boys in the hood soundtrack mm-hmm i
had minister
society in a row uh thicker than water
with mac tian
came along wow no i forgot about that
one i
i i was nominated for grammy with with
kendrick for the song
should have won that grammy yeah
macklemore yeah yeah
yeah but you get you but you get it you
know but
i've always embraced my position in
hip-hop
and i'm cool well when you when you it
with anything right
right when you look at other people and
you try to judge your own happiness
based on what other people are doing
that's where you get [ __ ] up man yeah
that's how [ __ ] become
depressed and they become unsure of
themselves
become [ __ ] up if you do that if i
start going damn
how come i ain't like snoop or how come
snoop drop the same [ __ ] i was rapping
or how come i'm like like kendrick or
quick or i've never done that because i
never felt like that
when you heard uh man i'm not gonna lie
some of those quick records were
were vicious on some rapping [ __ ] like
when he's
the one lying that stuck out to me when
i was the year e-i-h-t
now should i continue you left out the g
because the g-8 in you
you heard that what would you were you
like man [ __ ] this fool were you like
it's hip-hop were you like yo that was a
nice bar you have to come with good
lines in hip-hop
did you at least like respect his like
like
i don't think when you're beefing with
cats that you look at them as far as
oh whatever you know but i was never
like oh i'm feeling just blow the [ __ ]
up cause a [ __ ] i looked at it
as hip-hop banter
could you at least acknowledge like okay
quick i got something for you or like
yeah that line was kind of
that that was a cool line i've always
felt like i had perspective
in the hip-hop perspective i've always
felt that's just like a [ __ ]
saying that
i don't think i'm number one i'm number
two or number two nobody should
you always give yourself the credit of
whatever so in a hip-hop world
because i never took [ __ ] on record
personally
so yeah good line when [ __ ] would be
like oh that was wonky womb i said from
hip-hop perspective yeah it was a good
line
i mean just like [ __ ] would say
oh what you said was all killer or
whatever
whatever
right and i say it's all in the aspect
of trying to be clever
when you trying to diss a [ __ ]
right you can't disa [ __ ] on a
weak [ __ ] i tell [ __ ] today
i've been dissed by some of the best
[ __ ] so if you're gonna diss me you at
least got to come something right
correct
don't come with no weak [ __ ] because
then what's the point right
that's facts man yeah now we're just
people just make instagram videos about
each other
i mean [ __ ] [ __ ] make an
instagram video or do some dumb [ __ ] or
whatever but
like i said we came from the class of
of writing was everything man your pen
game man give a [ __ ] about the beat man
you got to write some [ __ ] cuz let's
face it a lot of [ __ ] had some
whackass [ __ ] tracks back in
the days too
but their [ __ ] penmanship was just
great like
you'd be like god damn man how did he
come up with that [ __ ]
so we prided ourselves on writing so you
had to come up with clever [ __ ] who
all's on the new album outside we know
conway primo who else
conway uh primo dave east
uh talib is on the new album yep yep
uh havoc my deep is on the album
uh corrupt
noble from the outlaws okay uh cocaine
shot cocaine yuck mouth mitchie slick
shout out to san diego man who else we
got on my girl
sherelle terry uh chill from cmw
uh who else is on the record
be real a lot of legends on this side so
yeah that's what i
i try to do a mix you know conway dave
east
uh and then uh you know go back to
people i admire
havoc corrupt [ __ ] noble
be real me and be real have done songs
you know as far as back to prelude to a
come up on the cypress hill record
and then me and mugs used to [ __ ] around
sole assassins whatever
so again be real i feel like there's
like a class of just
west coast guys who don't get enough
acknowledgement be real is one of them
you're one of them spice one like
there's a lot of guys
yeah definitely spice one brother lynch
hun shout out brother lynch shout out to
uh we we talked about king t earlier
exactly there's a lot of the licks
alcohol alcohol there's a lot of
underground heroes here
as far as west coast is concerned and
you know not to take away from nothing
from dre or snoop or cube because
that helps us as far as the west coast
is concerned
people stay with the identity of wex
hosts but we've had a lot of
we've had a lot of [ __ ] also
too like even in the in the 2000 like
early 2000s there was just like a whole
other offshoot of underground hip-hop
coming out la
that wasn't like dilated people's
exactly jurassic five
uh shout out to uh planet mers
planet asia roscoe cali agents there was
like
there was like a whole dope i just
remember
like i call it the fat beats [ __ ] right
right right yeah
the fat beat [ __ ] yeah we had a lot of
but like i said we don't get a
a lot of recognition over in the west
coast
which is sad but we have cats who will
still love hip-hop yeah
of course and they still no matter where
you are on that totem pole
just keep [ __ ] climbing that's how i
look at it [ __ ] it
if you oh if you ain't old enough and
you get no back spasms and [ __ ]
your legs ain't cramping up [ __ ] it keep
climbing the pole and [ __ ] because
there's a lot of good music that's being
offered
would you ever do another compton's most
wanted album yeah
i did a conscious most well me and chill
did a record we put it out independently
last
i want to say september it's called
gangster business okay
if you ain't heard about it go go peep
it out
some nice songs on there for sure just
trying to warm people back up
to getting back out there so yeah you've
been active man like i remember the
primo [ __ ] and then
i mean how many how many songs are on
this album 20.
20 is a little 20 piece i got a record i
just dropped in
february called official it's a double
album 27 songs
so it's got a song on there with
exhibiting problem
uh called profiles i just been working
man i've been working just trying to
stay working stay active
we know what the coronavirus [ __ ]
they shut a lot of [ __ ] down but
it's the perfect time for cats like
myself to